the problems were looking at solving
with a quantum computer are the problems
that today require age of the universe
timescales I'm not going to be around
for that solution some of these problems
literally require billions and billions
and billions of years to solve and on a
quantum computer what we've shown in
some recent research is that you can
solve some of these problems in a matter
of say weeks days hours seconds I'll be
around for those solutions you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen Hughes Inga
[Music]
if someone mentions quantum computing
and you find yourself outwardly nodding
your head but secretly shaking it you're
in good company some of the world's
smartest people admit they don't really
understand it either fortunately some of
the world's other smartest people like
dr. Christopher a principal research
manager of the Microsoft quantum or
quark group at Microsoft Research in
Redmond actually do understand quantum
computing and are working hard to make
it a reality today dr. Soares shares her
passion for quantum algorithms and their
potential to solve some of the world's
biggest problems
explains why Microsoft's topological
quantum bit or qubit is a game-changer
for quantum computing and assures us
that although qubits live in dilution
refrigerators at temperatures near
absolute zero quantum researchers can
still sit in the comfort of their
offices and work with the computer
programmers equivalent of Schrodinger's
cat that and much more on this episode
of the Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
so Krista your research revolves around
quantum algorithms tell us what's so
cool about quantum algorithms and how
you got interested in that line of
research quantum algorithms for me they
really serve the promise of being able
to solve things that we can't solve
today with digital computers quantum
quantum computing more generally really
unlocks this amazing potential for
computation and so for me quantum
algorithms are the ability to actually
do something with that computer right
algorithms being the recipes that you
run on the machine and so developing
quantum algorithms that can actually
solve real-world problems that are going
to make a difference that's a huge thing
a huge passion of mine to see how can we
actually change the world change you
know our outlook for clean energy or
food production you know things that
really affect humanity we have the
potential to solve some or at least help
combat some of those with quantum
algorithms and with a quantum computer
when did you decide quantum was the
algorithm of choice for you yeah that's
a good question
so I in college I studied mathematics
during my junior year I had a seminar
from Andrew Wiles who is a famous
mathematician he solved for mahse Last
Theorem and in that seminar he
introduced the idea it was a seminar on
cryptography and he introduced this idea
that there was this model of computation
that could break this crypto system that
we use all over today RSA based on the
problem of factoring and he introduced
that this model of computation quantum
computing namely could actually break
this crypto system and I became
fascinated that there was this other
model one could compute with and I also
had a keen interest in computer science
so I wanted to understand well how do
you use that model you know how would
you write an algorithm to do that how
would you design a programming language
and software stack to then implement
that algorithm on the hardware and that
started many years of study and
fascination with quantum computing so
we're assuming a fairly high level
of technical sophistication in our
listeners so it's not really a quantum
for dummies podcast but I think there's
room for a short elevator pitch on what
quantum computing is and how it differs
from classroom computing so two minutes
go yeah so with quantum computing you're
really relying on the principles of
quantum mechanics to compute and these
principles are just so vastly different
than what we have classically things
like superposition entanglement
interference
you know these terms if anyone's
listening to Fineman Richard Feynman and
his lectures or you know studied
Einsteins notes and papers you would
have come across these terms so
entanglement being this amazing ability
to have two systems that can be
correlated over you know universes apart
that when you do one to one thing it
automatically instantaneously does one
to another that's a pretty incredible
property and then things like
superposition so when I take a quantum
computer I rely on superposition to
store the information what that means is
instead of just having a bit in my
classical computer you know my classical
computer of course just binary it's on
or off it's a switch in a quantum
computer I like to think of it a little
bit like a dimmer switch right your
information is actually stored in a
quantum state and that quantum state can
take on both 0 and 1 it takes on
basically a linear combination of 0 and
1 and this allows you to then scale up
and achieve some of these amazing
exponential improvements with quantum
computing so you lead the Microsoft cork
was just quantum architecture and
computation group at Microsoft Research
and Redmond tell us about your team and
your partnerships and your vision for
quantum computing yeah so we started
quark now almost gosh I think it's seven
years ago we started embarking on the
idea that we wanted to determine what do
we do with a quantum computer it has all
this promise in all this potential and
then how are you gonna make it do that
right how are you going to program it
how are you gonna get that algorithm
into that
we're system and it uses these vastly
different principles right vastly
different systems
it requires classical computers unlike
any we've built before in addition to
this quantum computer and quantum system
we've never built before and so our
focus has been to really not only answer
those questions but then also make it
accessible to a broader community so
you've just done that talk about the kit
that you just released
yeah we're pretty excited we released
what we call the quantum development kit
and this quantum development kit is
really developed in order to make
quantum computing more accessible to
developers quantum enthusiasts students
academics researchers anyone who has a
keen interest to learn how to take
advantage of this amazing resource and
the kit includes of course a brand new
quantum focus domain-specific language
for quantum computing we call our
language cue sharp and cue sharp is
embedded in visual studio so not only do
you get this brand new language you know
then you also have in visual studio you
have all of these great things you can
take advantage of like debugging code
colorization you know syntax
highlighting help information when you
hover on functions and operations and so
it makes it that much more accessible
and hopefully you know lowers the
barrier of entry into quantum computing
do you have to be an expert in quantum
mechanics or quantum physics to
understand this field and start
developing for programming in it you
know we really hope that you don't you
know if we were limited to just looking
at developers that understood quantum
mechanics it might be a small group and
we want to really open up quantum
computing to a broad audience make it
accessible to everyone
and so the idea is that you need not
know quantum mechanics you know after
all I'm in this field I'm a computer
scientist I'm not a physicist I did not
take quantum mechanics in college you
know I came at this from the perspective
of a computer scientist someone who
wanted to use this to change computation
and so here we're hoping you know more
people want to come and learn about this
space and develop algorithms and
applications in this space and you need
not no quantum mechanics which is
fascinating because for people that are
wanting to get into quantum computing if
they're super high barriers to entry you
turn off a lot of people right off the
bat so how does Q sharp differ from
other programming languages since it's a
quantum tool and does it work on both
simulators and actual quantum computers
as we speak
yeah so Q sharp has really been designed
to target a quantum computer and the
model of computation you have in a
quantum computer it actually operates
hand-in-hand with a classical
programming language as well so what's
important to remember about a quantum
computer is that it's a hybrid device
it's like a coprocessor or an
accelerator so you would program much of
your application and kind of the wrapper
code in a standard language and then you
would call this Q sharp program that
then is the program that's really
specified to the quantum accelerator Q
Sharps design with that in mind and so
the whole idea is that Q sharp brings
with it the ability to easily set up
things like entanglement a superposition
use interference to design your quantum
algorithm and allow it to evolve a
functionality that's required in quantum
algorithms is very very different than
the functionality we use in classical
algorithms and so in Q sharp we bring
this right to the forefront so that it's
readily accessible to the developer
[Music]
one of the challenges in quantum
computing is the instability of qubits
that you think this concept of a
topological qubit may address or is
addressing so what's a topological qubit
and how will it help in quantum
computing right so with quantum
computing we rely on qubits right so
qubits are how we store information in
the quantum computer it stands for a
quantum bit so we say qubit and these
qubits what we have to realize is that
they want to interact all the time with
their environment this is not a good
thing for quantum computing we want them
to remain in vacuum isolated from
thermal noise and other noise processes
and so when they start to want to
entangle with their environment that
means that they get noisy that
entanglement with the environment causes
us to lose the information in the qubit
so we have to prevent that we have to
really isolate the system now there are
various ways to isolate the system and
the approach microsoft's taking is truly
unique and fundamentally more scalable
so the idea is that we should seek a way
to actually engineer into how we're
going to store and compute on the
information in the quantum computer
we should engineer that such that it's
more robust you know from the foundation
so imagine you want to build a
skyscraper and imagine I have a brick
and all of us you know we look at bricks
is extremely robust but try to build a
skyscraper out of bricks right it's very
very hard it's probably not the way you
want to go about it a better way is to
go employees steel so steel it's a
different type of foundation from which
to build this skyscraper but it's gonna
allow you to scale quickly it's gonna be
much more robust against changes you
know natural disasters whatever they may
be for the skyscraper and so arcuate is
like the steel qubit in our system with
the steel style qubit a topological
qubit as we call it we're going to be
able to scale much more readily and is
going to require less overhead less
additional resources less additional
cost less additional
right to get to higher numbers of
compute capability higher numbers of
qubits so you know one way to think
about it is we can do more with less we
can do more computation with fewer
qubits because they're like this steel
they're very very strong so it's
different kind of qubit exactly
altogether and it's unique to Microsoft
Research yes this qubit the topological
qubit actually Michael Friedman who
joined MSR in the late 90s he developed
the ideas behind this qubit with Alexey
Kiev who was at Microsoft at the time
and colleagues collaborators at several
universities the ideas of this qubit
have come out indeed out of Microsoft
and Microsoft research in particular
conceptualized here
yes exactly let's move over to the
system of quantum computing it doesn't a
continent and he's a bit of an ecosystem
tell the listeners a little bit about
what all has to happen to make a quantum
computer work in our constrained world
here again when we think about the
quantum ecosystem Microsoft has a very
unique approach and our approach is to
say that we want to build a
comprehensive scalable quantum system we
don't want to just build the quantum
computer you know that's gonna enable
fifty or hundred qubits so we want to
enable the quantum computer that's going
to scale to thousands ten thousands
hundreds of thousands of beyond that
will unlock truly amazing solutions to
the world's most challenging problems so
when we think about that ecosystem what
does it include at the one end we have
to have a qubit to store and compute the
information quantum mechanically that
qubit sits at millikelvin temperatures
in our system so to put that in
perspective that is very close to
absolute zero and so you have to
actually engineer first you have this
dilution refrigerator around the whole
system that maintains this cold
environment and this is also to help
protect the qubits against noise against
interacting and entangling with the
environment at the very top of this you
know think of as a system or stack we
want to us
the quantum computer to do something
right we want to program it so we're
writing quantum algorithms and I don't
know about the rest of the listeners but
I write quantum algorithms in room
temperature environments and so I'm
gonna have to interact with this system
that's sitting at almost absolute zero
you know close to minus 459 degrees
Fahrenheit and somehow we have to get
that program that controlled the
information everything down to that chip
that means that part of the system
requires an extensive control plane and
we also have to ask to run the quantum
you know subroutines if you will from a
classical program so we still need a
classical computer and that computer
sits at save for Kelvin and so we have
to engineer and design and develop not
only the quantum chip but this classical
computer that is unlike any classical
computer we've ever designed before its
operating at temperatures we've never
really tried to operate Costco computers
at before so we're designing that we're
designing the quantum chip itself and
then all the software right that
connects all of this and then from there
you have to compile that program to this
system and so we're developing not only
a complete hardware stack but also the
complete software stack so it sounds
like you have a multi disciplinary
expertise needed to pull this off
exactly so another key unique feature I
believe of our quantum program here at
Microsoft and Microsoft Research is
really our team so we have assembled
this amazing global team of experts that
have come together coming from you know
various fields it's not just physicists
you know you also need computer
scientists you need electrical engineers
you need cryogenic engineers right you
need the developers the software
engineers right I go on and on and we've
built this amazing quantum dream team
that's global sitting in more than 10
countries around the world
and together we're driving forward a
comprehensive quantum system and looking
at it from every angle and the people
that sit
this team are incredible I you know
Michael Friedman who helped start the
whole Quantum program at Microsoft
he's a Fields medalist in mathematics
right we have someone on our team who
founded craig computing we have another
person that's been the key architect at
Intel we have experimental physicists
that have been professors at Harvard and
Delft and we have people that have won
awards and computational physics right
you have all of these amazing absolutely
inspiring minds working on this problem
together including yours oh thank you
talk about cool when we talked before
you told me that quantum computers
already actually exist on a small scale
real ones not simulated environment
quantum computers how well are these
working now and what are the challenges
to scaling these systems it's exciting
to see that we have quantum computers in
a very small prototype setting in
existence today
now those quantum computers we have they
rely on this type of qubit that is
similar to this brick notion I mentioned
right and so what happens is their error
rates are not robust enough to scale
without having a lot of overhead to
achieve scale and when I say a lot it
means you know for each qubit that I
would express at the algorithm level I
may need somewhere between a thousand to
ten thousand physical qubits in my
quantum device to represent just one at
the algorithmic level we call that a
logical qubit now with the topological
qubit the type that we're working on
here at Microsoft the idea is that you
don't need that overhead it's built into
kind of the hardware level if you will
it's fundamental to how we design our
qubit from the beginning and so one
topological qubit you know we believe is
going to be equivalent to roughly a
thousand to ten thousand of these other
qubits
that's orders of magnitude yes indeed is
there even a hint that the topological
qubit is ready for primetime any
soon well we're working of course
actively and as quickly as possible to
develop a working prototype for the
quantum computer based on topological
qubits that would be big right now we
really think it's imminent this is just
an exciting time to be in this field and
in this place isn't it it's thrilling
it's like a total dream come true talk a
little bit about the impact that quantum
computing could have on things like AI
and machine learning sure so you know of
all things when I when I joined
Microsoft research a little over 11
years ago one of the first things I
worked on was machine learning here and
so I worked with the Bing team and
wonderful people there on ranking
algorithms for web search and other
things as well and it's pretty
remarkable that now you know at that
time I had done a PhD in quantum
computing and then gone on to learn some
machine learning at that time you know I
would not have expected that we would
then be merging those two fields in this
short you know roughly a decade period
of time and what do you know I think six
maybe six or so years ago now we started
working on our first quantum machine
learning algorithms and I really think
we've pushed the boundary there in the
last few years so we're really excited
to be able to show speed ups in quantum
machine learning so by using a quantum
algorithm to do training of say a deep
neural network or a Boltzmann machine or
perceptron you can get speed ups in
terms of those training times I think
what is perhaps even more fascinating is
that in quantum machine learning you
have this device you have this quantum
computer at your fingertips that can
model nature which goes back to things
that Fineman referred to you know it's
amazing
entrancing capability of nature to do
things with the quantum computer you can
be able to actually compute closer to
how nature computes and when we think
about that you know what does that
mean for unlocking patterns or you know
models in speech and language and vision
I think it's pretty remarkable and what
we see is that when you add some of
these quantum properties or quantum
terms to models this can greatly enhance
the model of the data or the model of
the information at hand you actually get
fundamentally different things out right
so on the same note tell me what the
potential impact is on things like
cryptography security privacy because on
that side of things it seems in my mind
anyway that there's great promise and
also great risk right so one of the
earliest kind of algorithms we have
dating back to 1994 is this algorithm by
Peter shor that shows that you can
perform what's called factoring on a
quantum computer efficiently now why do
we care about factoring well this is
what underlies pretty much every digital
encryption scheme we use pretty much
every crypto system on the Internet and
of course one things oh wow
right a quantum computer is going to
attack and break this crypto system
right that feels like a threat however
the great news is that there are crypto
systems that aren't able to be attacked
by a quantum computer and this is
something Microsoft Research is also
doing we have a whole team here looking
at what are those protocols that are
going to be robust against quantum
attacks against quantum computers
breaking them and these are classical
systems classical systems that can
easily and readily replace things like
RSA these protocols have been put forth
Brian LaMacchia Steam and Microsoft
Research for example has been working on
this and they have protocols that they
believe are robust and of course it will
take you know maybe a decade to switch
over the software all the calls to RSA
in our present software but if we start
today we will be you know fundamentally
ready so when a quantum computer of the
size required to break RSA exists we
won't be using it to break RSA we're
going to be using it to solve you know
these amazing
problems we have in the world you know
clean energy food production so forth
carbon capture because we will have
robust security systems so you're
looking at both sides of the issue both
right making it and preventing it from
exactly yeah we know that there there's
a way to prevent this and that's by
bringing forth what we call post quantum
crypto methods these are the classical
methods that will be robust against
quantum attacks and they exist and
they're being well studied NIST for
example in the United States is looking
over these protocols and is going to put
forth which one you know one should
switch to
that's all happening in real time you
said one of the good things about
quantum research is that it's revealing
issues both about quantum computing and
classical computing at the same time so
what kinds of things are you discovering
yeah what's great is when you start
studying another field often it lends
these amazing insights back to some
other field and in this case when we
look at quantum computing it's pretty
amazing we've learned a lot about
classical computing and actually when we
start working on quantum machine
learning we thought oh my gosh we've
found an exponential speed-up over the
state of the art for quantum computing
right a quantum algorithm to do machine
learning and when we dug under the hood
we realized oh my gosh these ideas apply
to classical machine learning and so we
sped up the classical algorithm that's a
great outcome of studying quantum
computing and this is now happening you
know that's just one example but this is
happening repeatedly in machine learning
optimization theoretical computer
science we're learning more and more
about classical functions about how to
do classical optimization and we're
improving those methods greatly drawing
from ideas that we're learning because
we're looking at quantum computing and
quantum algorithm design and so forth
[Music]
what was your path to Microsoft Research
how'd you end up here so I did my PhD at
Columbia University in computer science
and my advisor there I was a huge fan or
is I should say is a huge fan of
Microsoft Research and had suggested I
look at Microsoft Research as a
potential place to come and at the time
I was doing a PhD in quantum computing
my dissertation was on fault tolerant
scalable quantum computing which is what
I'm still doing today and so I became
quite interested in looking at Microsoft
I had heard it was this incredible
environment and it employed the most ph
d--'s in computer science of anywhere on
the planet in school you often think an
academic you know university position is
the only place that you can go forward
and continue research and publication
and collaboration and so forth and yet
here was this amazing amazing
institution that had more PhDs and more
people studying computer science and and
how to use it to you know really change
different aspects of our technology
landscape and so I thought wow that
looks up like a pretty amazing place to
look at so I looked at it and what do
you know I ended up here yeah I forget
who said it think it might have been
Michael Friedman that Microsoft is the
largest curiosity driven research
enterprise in the world oh I love that I
think that curiosity and creativity
those are two things you see so much of
here and such an enthusiasm to learn
something new and to work with others
that aren't quite in the same you know
vein of research you're in there are so
many amazing people they're all here
right at your fingertips and the more
you reach out the more you learn and
again it goes back to contributions
going all directions right that helps us
advance not only quantum computing but
it feeds back ideas to to their line of
research and it's just this incredible
growth of
ideas and an output and impact though
you can't go down and get coffee without
bumping into three geniuses right which
is a great thing it's a treat to go get
coffee around here right because you
ultimately end up in some incredible
conversation and you learn something new
every single time I was going to say I
bet the water cooler conversations
around here are sort of on another level
right sometimes and I would have to say
it's encouraging for me to note on the
blog that announced the the kit the dev
kit that just came out there's a quote
that even some of the smartest people in
the world confess they don't understand
quantum computing and then when I
clicked on that link because it was in
blue it took me to Bill Gates yes I
don't feel so bad as we close I have to
ask is there any work going on in the
quantum snack-food
lines of research because I'm always
looking for something yummy that's both
more filling and less something that's
good for you and bad for you actually
doing a circle back to another question
because I think every time we talk about
something that has the big potential for
good we also have to look at the big
potential for bad and quantum seems the
most intimidating because how hard it is
to understand
mm-hmm but also what the promise is talk
to me about the length of time needed to
solve say an np-hard problem versus what
we can ask today of a computer yeah so
when we think about quantum computing
it's important I think first to realize
that quantum computers aren't going to
replace all computers we have today it's
really going to solve a special class of
problems a certain class kind of similar
to how we use supercomputers right we're
not using supercomputers to do our email
or Word documents or right you're not
yeah I wish I mean maybe I get more
email done but you know it's it's really
a special purpose device we don't send
every subroutine to a GPU when we're
programming right so you know you have
to look at what problems you want to
send to a quantum computer and not every
problem will be
by a quantum computer but a pretty
incredible set of problems are sped up
by a quantum computer and that happens
to be problems in the areas of you know
as we talked about machine learning and
artificial intelligence but but also the
simulation of physical systems so
studying quantum chemistry studying
problems in the space of like catalysis
potentially medicine health optimization
problems these problems are great
candidates for getting a quantum
speed-up as we say or you know for
getting a fundamentally different
solution and they unlock their really
the problems we're looking at solving
with a quantum computer are the problems
that today require age of the universe
timescales right wait those yeah age of
the universe I'm not going to be around
for that solution I don't know about you
but I might yeah but age of the universe
timescale is a very very long time to
wait for a solution now you know
problems as I just mentioned in
catalysis like when we look at trying to
understand how a catalyst will improve a
reaction rate some of these problems
literally require billions and billions
and billions of years to solve using not
just you know today's super computers
but post exascale supercomputers also
will see the same type of time
requirements and on a quantum computer
what we can show and what we've shown in
some recent research is that you can
solve some of these problems in a matter
of say weeks days hours seconds all of
those time frames seem very doable
I will definitely but you know I'll be
around for those solutions
so going from billions of years to a
week or a month you know we we train
machine learning models for months all
the time oh my so we're looking at
really bringing down you know really
unlocking solutions for some of these
problems with quantum computing so is
there anything in what you've just said
that keeps you up at night about that
information
well what keeps me up at night is I want
us to get there faster you know I think
about gosh you know how can we unlock
and more the ability to program this
device because the potential is so huge
and I think that's so exciting that we
could potentially combat global warming
with a solution coming from a quantum
computer in conjunction with solutions
from classical computers right that's
pretty amazing that this device could
help us do that it could help us better
produce artificial fertilizer and in
turn help food production that could
help us better model machine learning
and the unlocks are so huge that what
keeps me up at night is just I wanna
there's not enough time in the day to
get all of this done you know you want
to work so fast at this because it it's
so promising and so exciting that it's
hard to want to go to sleep that's
awesome that's a closer
[Laughter]
Christus Laurie thanks for coming in
today well thank you so much it's
inspiring to hear your passion and cool
stuff you're doing yeah well everyone go
download the quantum development kit and
we'd love to see a quantum community
really really develop here no pun
intended
yeah exactly
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. christenbury
and Microsoft's distinct approach to
quantum computing visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]